takes 11 on your Monday morning the 2022  Global Gaming Expo in town starts today  at the Venetian it shows off the latest  and greatest in gambling and e-gaming  Technologies there's a company called  light and wonder what do they used to be  Scientific Games yeah they're right here  in town the VP of sales is the company's  really focused on gaming across  platforms  we give players the games they want to  play anywhere they want to play so  whether that's your local casino or if  you play from your mobile device on a  Social Casino site which is play for fun  or free  or if you live in a state that allows  online real money wagering you'll also  find our content there as well  they're talking about New Concepts  they're going to be debuted then they  often show up on Casino floors a year or  so later g2e is running through Thursday